royals they're just like us and prince
william is sharing a rare look into his
family's morning routine the duke of
cambridge opened up on apple fitness
plus's time to walk audio walking series
about how mornings in his house can be
quite the production especially when it
comes to his eight-year-old son prince
george and his six-year-old daughter
princess charlotte who he says kick off
most mornings with a quote massive fight
about what music they play william solve
alternate who gets to pick the tunes
each day quote george gets his go then
charlotte gets her go as for
three-year-old prince louis he gets in
on the action too joining his older
siblings for a daily dance party
charlotte particularly is running around
the kitchen in her dresses and ballet
stuff and everything she goes completely
crazy with louie following her around
trying to do the same thing and despite
the morning chaos the 39 year old royal
says quote it's a really happy moment
where the children just enjoy dancing
messing around and singing so what kind
of music are the kiddos jamming out to
ac dc and a tina turner classic
[Music]
which williams says reminded him of his
late mother princess diana who used to
sing the song at the top of her lungs
while driving william and his younger
brother prince harry to boarding school
quote you'd be singing and listening to
the music right the way out into the
gates of school when they dropped you
off when i listen to it now it takes me
back to those car rides and brings back
lots of memories of my mother william
also revealed the kids love to listen to
a little shakira and when the 44 year
old grammy winner caught wind of that
she reacted on twitter writing quote i'm
so pleased you like my music princess
charlotte and with the holidays right
around the corner many are wondering how
the royals will be spending christmas
this year amid ongoing tension following
harry's decision to step back from his
senior royal duties in 2020 and his
explosive tell-all interview alongside
his wife meghan markle with oprah
winfrey earlier this year there's
clearly still a lot of hurt a lot of
resentment and a degree of mistrust i
think on both parts william and harry's
grandmother 95 year old queen elizabeth
spent the night in the hospital for
tests and observations back in october
and has yet to meet the duke and duchess
of sussex's newborn daughter lilibet two
factors that royal expert katie nicol
told et might contribute to prince harry
returning to the uk from california for
the holidays there has been a lot of
speculation that harry would like to
come back and see his family for
christmas and obviously there is there
is still a lot of speculation about
familial relationships and i don't think
certainly by any means things are all
fixed um but of course you know this is
the queen's grandson and she will want
to see harry i'm sure she's going to be
desperate to meet her her
great-granddaughter lilly bert who's of
course named after her and to see archie
so i think the hope is that there will
be an opportunity for for some kind of
family reconciliation and i i can't see
them all gathered around the table at
christmas i mean that's a bit optimistic
and ambitious but um you know harry is
going to be very aware of his
grandmother's health is going to be very
concerned and it's understandable he
will want to be coming over at some
point and whether that's on his own or
with his family to come and see the
queen